well what's weird is I heard a por star
go yeah I'm just like boring at home
right yeah they're all missionary people
at home and like dude if I'm the [__]
boyfriend dude no yeah no dude no dude
cuz you got to outo whatever happened
that day do me like that bro of course I
just saw you get F I just saw you get
yeah I mean dude you can't do what I
just saw you do and be like I'm lazy
tonight I'm just going it's like n yeah
it's like you marry a chef and they only
make PB and JS when they're home I
remember this one porn star she goes
like crying she was crying and I feel
bad she was like crying and she's going
you know this job is such a the stigma
and she goes like I would come home and
my boyfriend didn't even want to kiss me
right away I'm like yeah you yeah you
got the DNA of [__] five dudes on you
I'm [__] go jump in a sauna was it
fun on set who was there today and she's
like Mark and Rick and Tony and Bill and
Kong and you're like okay Kong dude oh
how's Kong doing